in this session we have two two dogs the
first one by Massey Civic is the bigger
machines how computers can be can you
all hear me well Paula okay that's
perfect so what I also a little bit
about me laughter you know who I am
so basically matcha tea bag is almost
you can't tell that how to pronounce
seeing how it's written because at the
Polish name so they never seem to be
pronounced hardly written so I live in
London right now
but work remotely for the company called
nforce QA which we kind of do the
automation of the web tests that I am
part of data science teams are and I'm
more on the engineering side than the
Mac side so yeah
this talk will be kind of non-technical
which will see it will be obvious so it
will be boring so I'm sorry about that
we taking all of the obvious stuff but I
really believe that this the things that
I will talk about are really important
so okay I have to go that way okay so
yeah how we perceive machines how humans
see machines right now basically for us
they are logical and calculating so they
are don't have emotions they are always
using the algorithms that are almost
always right never wrong they are
reliable and if they make mistakes
because they do from time to time the
mistakes are they do are pretty absurd
so I mean we can see on the slide of the
translation going wrong it was totally
wrong and you can always say that it's
wrong so I think that that makes us kind
of more inclined to believe in the
results that
gasps because we like if there's a bad
result oh yeah it's like totally easily
seen as a bad result for example I know
there's like visual QA you ask the
machine so how many dogs are in this
picture and the answer is pineapple okay
it's absurd so the mistakes are there
but they are really good causes
or at least we think so so we seen them
as transporting so there was even a cool
experiment pretty recently where people
have been locked in a auditory like
dancing like that and there was an
emergency evacuation robot and people
were told that this robot is not working
it's faulty and they shouldn't follow
this instruction but then they started
to pull Papa push the smoke into the
room and people were panicked and we're
running away and they indeed were
following the robot even if it was like
going into like some small corridors
totally opposite of the exit so people
trust machines and we all do that so we
believe that they are objective and free
of any biases so we can basically know
feel and trust them that they want like
the result that we get from all the
models won't be tainted by symmetry
notions or given any biases like there
won't be racist or sexist or some why
not partly that we believe right so
that's the one thing and it's like okay
I'm going somewhere with that so the
machines we also give them the power so
right now I think we thought that they
will be assistants in the
decision-making process so we will use
computers as guidance for our decisions
they will be helping us to make better
and better informed decisions and that's
what we hoped for
turns out it's more like they are
decision makers so we kind of gave them
even more power now all the men of
different decisions are made just by
machines they no longer serve the
assistant for the human to make
decisions the
I make that decisions themselves so few
examples like those computer sets of
scenarios you go to defiantly go
somewhere you want to I know
get a credit or buy something and you
apply computer set no and the person is
kind of helpless right the computer said
so and I can't influence that so yeah
the computer has a power to decide and
the example is overbooking which
actually happened to me when I was
coming here so I was supposed to take a
slide that was 2 p.m. and I will land
here around 5 p.m. but apparently
computer decided to sell even more
tickets
so the fighters overbooked and I arrived
here at around 1:00 a.m. so I might be
retired yeah and that happened and that
happened because we gave the power to
the machines to make decisions and even
if they are supposed to be assistants in
the decision-making open people just
from the laziness or the ease of it rely
on those assistants we should take them
as a factor and thing about other staff
and lady then make a decision but
sometimes is easy are we dancing a go
with what the Machine set so the power
of the machines is huge and the thing
that they're it's on the rise and that's
because of the advances in machine and
so it's also been exciting right we are
all here because of it like we all like
deep learning especially my left eye
that's my favorite and that's what I do
so it's awesome amazing and it's getting
easier and that's I think also a key to
be more careful with them so we are
giving them even more power enabling
them to make even more decisions than
they were there weren't be able to them
before because they couldn't now we can
just throw everything into a machine
learning systems crewe so
on linear algebra and we get an answer
there so we basically make a way for
machines to make more different
decisions and butters and hidden cost we
increase capacity at the same time so
the deep learning models are harder to
explain kind of sometimes not even
explainable at all so we can try to do
some different visuals at these
valuations of activations on different
layers but it's hard to tell what's
going on inside this neural net which is
like huge has many different layers so
we are not really sure what's going on
inside there and that makes it dangerous
so we give them that power to decide
about our lives but they are opaque at
the same time so we don't really know
what's going on and I think that
provides to be dangerous or at least we
should take extra care though and I
guess we can all assume that people who
will use them are responsible or
something like that
well turns out that direct quote from
the article that was recently published
it wasn't peer reviewed so but basically
the article is called automated
inference on criminality using size
images and there's this quote that's how
the article begins we study for the
first time automated interest interest
on community based solely on still face
images okay which is free of any biases
of subjective judgment amounts of human
observers and I thought like I told Anna
oh boy
I am for a tree to Rivet article so it
was pretty recent example it was
mentioned in my mainstream press and
they claimed to have achieved like 90%
accuracy using Alex on it which is kind
of even better than what other people
were
watch if in with Alexa net in case of
the gender recognition so apparently
that their network is can like recognize
the criminals better than other people's
can recognize who is women and who is a
man just on the faces Oh probably
something is not right here probably so
right answers one questions basically
then machine learning models will try
the best to learn what we throw at them
so we can throw at them anything and
they will try to produce set of features
that make them a bit like the day that
will enable them to classify the data
into two separate set or whatever many
sets you have in there in this article
they had to sense because like they had
criminal and non-criminal so you
probably thought about it and something
comes out of it but if there's literally
the question is wrong like if you can't
really tell that if someone is criminal
or not from the face alone which
actually has been studied before it's
been studied for quite a while and it's
been proven to be wrong for a long time
so there's like no way and it will start
on a humans and humans are really good
at recognizing faces so I mean we can
argue that maybe the deep learning
network is better but I'm not convinced
about that so we are probably trying to
solve the problem that cannot be solved
and we are throw the products or the
data into a network and we will get an
answer but this answer will be probably
not that's good so there's a saying like
a drowning man will clutch at a straw
and that's what the model will try to do
so even if there are no features like
that underlying features you can try to
generate a set of features that will be
able to dis classified to two different
classes but are those classes what we've
been
they are are those labels that we put
them at the end
oh yeah this is the criminal and this is
non-criminal imaginary Moodle can't know
that
like it can't know that those classes or
the class labels are right they can it
can't sleep there and a title to
different classes but we named those
classes and that's enough so also a
thing like there might be many false
correlations in there so we can for
example see that maybe the model very
simple correlation that actually using
those photos for example testosterone
level or something like that it is
possible but it doesn't mean that like
this is this is a classifier for the
criminality so this is an example what
the faces look like in sagittal so those
who are labeled as criminals also known
criminals and so what I see here if I
maybe one smiling you're smiling kind of
right they look smiling a little while
so I like to smile so I will be
classified as a known criminal and
that's cool but maybe that would've done
and here I will not lie quite well so
maybe I will be even criminal here so we
never know what if and you can fly with
him that's what I hear on those pictures
so the data selection can't be tainted
and that's what give us mass washing
this is pretty cool term coined by Fred
Benenson so basically what it means we
use algorithms and different data linear
data algebra or we just throw data at
the network and we have the result which
we think is unbiased but it will have a
bias because the data set was propelled
by humans so it will have our inherent
bias
like I don't we challenges wrong wing we
have like made a mistake when the
breaking the data we can't try to avoid
them but there will always be n like
different biases concerning the data set
because the way we made the data set
will be biased somehow so we're seeing
those results of the free of any biases
just like in this article free of any
biases and the human judgment mile it
turns you and that's really the interest
and we should be aware of that so there
is a company that's called I think I
section or something like that they try
to capitalize on coming like in this
article so basically they try to
recognize the character tags from places
and I they will try to capitalize and
convince I the government or somebody
that it can't be done well it's really
hard to do in my opinion and it's near
impossible to do correctly and in about
unbiased way so it is dangerous and we
should be aware and worried when we
should be able to see where it starts to
go the wrong way where and I can't
imagine for example an admission system
to the University where you provide your
face and itself
oh are you smart enough to be a part of
our university which is super bad super
bad idea but maybe it will happen right
why not
why to bother with doing any testing or
whatnot well you can just pop in your
face right since simple but it's really
so even if there is like some easy to
spot biases right
you chose the data wrong way or you
partition with them incorrectly or you
are biased in selection or some classes
or not there are always some things and
data and which are hard which is hard to
spot so for example the faces which they
collected from the convicted criminals
and here the
criminals were convicted by human judges
so we are back under human judgment
because those classes seem to be
objectively coming from somewhere
because it's objective right you have
the database of convict convicts and
that's where you pull those images from
so it should be objective right but they
are there because somebody convicted
them and judge them as a criminal in the
first place so it might be that there is
something that we recognize entices as
extremely or maybe not trustworthy and
that makes those judges more prone to
judge them as a criminal or not and that
was the neural net picture so I mean
it's kind of can be abusing basically
state is I think one of the problems
where you have the black people who are
convicted much at much higher rate with
much severe sentences and if you try to
build that's a set on this data which is
totally objective you'll get the same
result like you will be more likely to
classify black people as as a criminals
which is something that's true but other
things that's connected with predictive
policing so basically what they are
trying to do in some of the states now
is to figure out where to send police
patrols and this do they try to like
mostly push the like number of arrests
or number of people caught doing some
nasty things so it seems like okay kind
of objective right the crimes happened
there so we should send more puzzles
though since seems quite object it for
me but in the end the data is painted as
well because in the first place those RS
happened there because some human
decided those are the high-risk areas so
there were more puzzles beforehand
because some human was biased made
not send those puzzles and that's where
the whether there are more hours in the
very etiquette there are more puzzles
that and it all comes down to somebody
somewhere down lines
that's what oh yeah we should send more
patterns that because those are higher
crime rate areas so right now we kind of
must wash it again see okay that's all
objectives are more arrests and so now
we have a system that totally unbiased
showing us that there are more those
areas are more like there are more
trying to this area another thing that
is like it's a feedback loop or runaway
effect which is we use the data and then
we retrain those networks on the data
homes so we started the predictive
policing we started a human bias which
was already sending the passwords to the
different areas so we use it as a seed
data that we retrain our networks using
the basically what that network
predicted like where we should send
puzzles within more patrols there and it
kind of creates confirmation bias
because there will be more arrests in
those areas because that's where we send
the patrols and it has like it goes
round around and which we train the
network even more on this new data which
was generated by the networks and goes
on and on and on and I think is the same
case for example with the convicted
criminals as you can see using this kind
of network as an assistant to judges who
will be depending on it really heavily
so that might create another bias and
more people which have actually those
facial features convicted more and then
we retrain the network Enrique we have
this huge mass of bias which is my first
instinct as an unbiased and free from
any human judgment okay
although you really think that kind of
forgotten by the practitioners is
forgetting about the societal impact of
the models we are creating so every
model we create will influence people's
lives well probably every one maybe not
every single one but we will create a
models that we that will have a societal
impact and if when we are creating those
models we can be really close on them
and see oh yeah I'm doing better my
classification rate is going higher and
that's cool and awesome and I'm really
happy about that but forgetting a lot of
the bigger picture
how did real straight into society after
you are done with your model and you
want to put it to the world to for
everybody to use it's pretty easy to
show that this is how it will impact
society because it's kind of obscure in
some ways so for example the criminal
model utterances into challenges well I
mean it can be seen that somebody will
come up with an idea maybe we should try
to use it as a trick of how the criminal
is really clean arable and maybe will
help us with the length of conditions
convictions because if he has a pace
that tastes like he is a criminal then
we will judging much more severe and
lock him up for a longer period of time
than if you want very non criminal face
then maybe it was a mistake he just
slipped up and we should just lock him
for two weeks or something maybe it was
a mistake
right so it is conceivable that somebody
might want to use that in this way and
you when somebody creating those models
they don't necessarily think about all
those implications that of smokes might
have in the real world other one is
hiring culture so that basically you
create a model
a deep learning network to help a
corporation with hiring so you take tons
of data about your current employees
take the social media feeds every single
piece of data you can get on them and
try to learn how it correlates
performance so we for example can have
the high performers take those data
about them and hire just the higher
performance people so it's possible that
because there were articles that point
out that you can't predict a future
depression based on somebody's social
media feed feed so you can see how like
there are likely to become depressed
soon enough and it's kind of possible
that it might be a hidden feature
Supremes hidden feature somewhere in
your deep network you will not know that
like it will become emergent from the
social media feed or something like that
it will be somewhere in there and you
will not be even aware of it but it is
ethical to them use that classifier and
if it works it helps having better
people hire better performers by the
names we are getting into great area of
an ethics and I think the deep learning
and data science is one we should be
concerned with the ethical and social
impact of our work with single every
single line of our code can't decide
about somebody's life I mean it's I
wouldn't be able to tell that the
JavaScript conference for example and
that's why I think it's so important to
talk about this stuff here because it's
easy to forget about it so yeah future
depression of hidden feature maybe a
little maybe not well I'm not here to
judge but it is something to be aware of
that those machines those models can
learn stuff that
basically not that clear for us in the
first light and even harder to then dig
into is there a solution to it is there
a solution to this problem because right
now I'm kind of showing a dark side of
the deep learning is pretty great bad
either a solution to this problem which
we are facing as a community I think
like one of the best solution to this is
actually awareness so we should be aware
of all those biases and different social
societal impact our model might have so
if we know what we are creating and if
we are aware of those things we can try
to counteract it it can try to make the
users of those models our as well that
this model might be biased in such and
such a way so awareness I think is
really important and I think just one of
the takeoffs here just to have somewhere
in your mind that those models are
buying your mobile is probably biased
when you might try to make it as
unbiased as possible but somewhere deep
down it kind of is and it has this human
connection of human judgment built deep
into one of the layers
another thing is you should always be
aware that your models will have an
impact on human life for example
somebody might not have a good night's
sleep before his talk so yeah they will
impact a human life in a more like maybe
in some small way but there might be
some really huge decisions based on the
models that we create like hiring or
admission to university or tests around
other situations where we actually use
the model so I think those two things
like if you can remember in the future
there was this guy pretty tall which was
talking and he tries to make you aware
of those two things it would be I was so
happy so remember that your model is
probably somewhere biased and your model
will have an impact on human life so
those two things together and quite
important and I mean I know it feels
kind of fine we are technical why we
should we care about all this snap but I
think we are in a place and especially
we've data science that we need to care
about it because it's on us so it's on
us to not be just to makers that create
a model and then just give it to
somebody you use it and it's your
responsibility and your ethical
decisions like for example weapon makers
do right they make guns and that's what
our is mostly how those guns will be
used right they might be used for good
day like this for wrong but we don't
care and we probably should not go that
way because we've guns at least people
understand how they work and with models
and especially the planning models we
have a problem to understand what's
going on so like somebody who will be
using this one is like probably not
knowing anything about it so I think we
should act as some kind of educators so
when you create a model when you ship it
sell it to somebody ship it to
production make the users of your more
aware or what are its shortcomings how
it might be biased in what way if it
might not do what we advertise or what
might be hidden somewhere on some layer
like the depression picture which if we
tell about it
softly fine I think for those people who
are will be using them to make an
informed decision so yeah pretty much it
thank you for attention
sorry thanks man see for your speech is
there any question hello hi first of all
thank you for your beautiful talk I
think that then the topic is very
interesting actually
and it's very act well - so the question
is it's not actually a question it's
more a comment because I think that
actually it's very true that the machine
learning is a model man in his mother
cell buyers because our data is bias but
actually machine learning is telling you
it's telling us something about the
buyer so in principle if you know that
your problem should not be biased and
then you find correlation that usually
you are not expecting actually you are
you are the answer you know that we are
discriminating that by gender or
etcetera so I think it's we have an
opportunity right now that we haven't in
the past because we can actually show we
can actually demonstrate to people that
these buyers exist in our data and so we
can i will not say filter but at least
take in account because you know for
example there in in companies always
they they use statistics in the way that
they want because they can use I mean
instead of another because it's
reflecting better they the Excel system
so what I mean is that I think now we
have an open opportunity what do you
think you are you are working on this on
analyse bias actually extracting this
value and demonstrate I know I'm
actually working on something like only
the deep learning networks but that's
more of a hobby than my day-to-day work
that I do so I use them basics to help
automate the test by classifying the
screenshots of webpages but
yeah I totally agree review there was
quite recent study as well where they
found about them they were testing water
embeddings and they found that they are
really heavily gender biased and what
they were learning them on it's actually
a Google News so they were learning them
on the set of the from the newspapers we
should be probably unbiased but there
was like really heavy bias it was like
sex is biased writer they were like
really under like a little I think
they're one of those they were like
doing the vector math and one of the
something keys to something like
something into something and there's
like men if the programmer like woman is
to home maker which is which was in
there so I mean if we are not aware of
it yeah we can learn this water mending
and not Bureau but if you are ever also
biases and you check for them then yeah
I certainly agree we can use it as an
opportunity to be more aware of where we
are introducing biases and where our own
biases are coming from so yeah I hope
when I agreed that our questions
very interesting talk perhaps this
question goes seconds it's very spirit
but do you are you aware of any
mathematical way to characterize this
kind of biases so yeah there's a lot of
work done right now so I made on tooth
not that technical because we are I want
to be more like humanity oriented talk
but yeah there are tons of different
research being done on this place on the
space especially it has to be done right
now because actually even the law
regulations so for example in the states
you have the law that you can't
basically discriminate against any
minorities so they have a law that
prevents them from doing that and then
there's whole tool set on how to change
and how to detect if your model is
biased in one way or the other based on
those protected minority criterions so
it has to be done and basically because
it's required by law and I think the
other thing that is slowly coming up
depression is the European Union law
about the explained ability of models
like right to explain for the models
which yeah which is I think actually
needed because you know so you are aware
that your model might be discriminating
some money and this is like the we also
need whole proof set on how to check if
our models are biased and how to try to
explain them so it might slow down the
development especially of the deep
learning design is hard to make them and
like adoption of them but I think this
kind of is so yeah
[Applause]